all right we're on
welcome everybody we've got about an
hour until the CNN healthcare debate
happens and I want to sort of preview
what we might see explain what the
relevant topics of discussion might be
explained to you warn you about the red
herrings and straw men that you are
likely to hear and also take your
questions talk to you about a few things
coming up on the show
etc so I'll wait just a couple of
minutes for people to connect a lot of
different things going on we do have now
have had it for a couple of weeks we
have donors who contribute via super
chat or through the stream labs link in
the video description your name and
donation will come up here and when you
make a donation a cool animation will
play right around here
we'll have to wait until that actually
happens to see it you can use super chat
to send in your questions you can use
stream labs comm slash the david pakman
show to send in your question so the
questions can be about the healthcare
debate that we were going to see on CNN
in an hour or they can really be about
anything else if you want I'm glad to
answer all questions and respond to all
comments if this is your first live
stream I will tell you that we are live
that's sort of the point of it today in
particular we are live because in an
hour with the CNN health care debate
about Trump Care 3.0 happens and I'll
tell you who the debaters will be and we
will talk about what we might expect to
see very very soon thanks to covet hour
Bob who has just made a contribution
there is the Super Mario animation love
that number two you can use super chat
to communicate questions and comments
that's the dollar sign at the bottom of
the chat window but you can also use
stream labs.com slash the david pakman
show the animation will play your name
will show up up here no matter which of
the two you do but when you use super
chat we will skip the 30% contribution
I'm sorry 30% deduction that YouTube
takes from Super chats so that's
something to consider and number three
any new members and patrons who make
Contribution or sign up during the
livestream we'll get a shout out and a
thank you from me live on the stream I
will sing your praises and it's all
going to be just absolutely fantastic we
are at 1933 patrons right now I am
targeting 2000 but I will make the
following proposal to you if during the
live stream we can get to 1950 1950
patrons even if it's just seventeen
dollar pledges I will create and
announce for you a 55 percent membership
discount code okay we currently don't
have one we have a 40 percent discount
code off of membership which is I voted
seventeen but if we get to 1950 patrons
I will make a new coupon code maybe
it'll be related to Bernie and
medicare-for-all or something like that
since that is relevant to what we're
talking about today but again the target
is 1950 patrons any contribution amount
gets us closer patreon.com slash david
pakman show and lastly please don't
troll the chat okay obvious trolling and
hate will get you banned moderator
Lauren is uh is getting in on the action
we have I'm not sure which other
moderators we have today but they are
there and just don't do it okay just
don't do it it's not funny and it is not
fun so let's talk about what we can
expect to see in this debate if you
haven't heard about this debate I should
actually backtrack if you haven't even
heard about what's going on with health
care Trump care 1.0 was proposed and
failed to pass Trump care 2.0 was
proposed and failed to pass and whether
we call these Republic air the
Affordable Care the American Health Care
Act or Trump care doesn't really matter
to me but for tonight we'll call them
Trump care and we now have Trump Care
3.0 propose proposed this is known as
the Graham Cassidy bill this one is even
more depraved I would argue than Trump
care 1.0 and 2.0 it would repeal
basically all aspects of the Affordable
Care Act also known as Obamacare which
has no shortage of flaws as most of you
know and I've outlined for many many
years but it would do more than just
that by basically allowing for
insurance companies to price gouge
people with pre-existing conditions
people who get sick after purchasing
insurance which sort of defeats the
entire purpose of what insurance even is
and there are a couple of different
estimates but not yet from the CBO but
there is every indication that thirty to
thirty two million people will end up
uninsured over the next ten years over
the ten years after the implementation
of Trump Care 3.0 if it does happen now
the debate tonight will be the two
senators after whom the bill is named
Lindsey Graham and Senator is it Bill
Cassidy I forget his first name Graham
and Cassidy they will be arguing in
favor of their bill and senators Bernie
Sanders and Amy Klobuchar
will be arguing debating against the
bill now Bernie Sanders is in a very
interesting position for this debate
because not only is he opposed
conceptually to what the Graham Cassidy
bill Trump Care 3.0 proposes but Bernie
Sanders has his own bill which he has
put out there the Medicare for all 2017
proposal I believe is what it's called
which I mean that to call it the
complete opposite I don't know
it is drastically different than Trump
Care 3.0 it proposes getting us out of
this for-profit employer connected
health insurance sort of paradigm that
we find ourselves in and I think it will
be interesting to have Bernie Sanders
there I think it'll also be interesting
to have Amy Klobuchar participate just
because she I think is a great in these
sorts of formats and I think that she
will be very interesting to watch and
again that's at 9:00 p.m. Eastern
currently 8:05 p.m. Eastern on September
25th if you are not watching live that's
when the stream is happening so I think
that the debate is actually kind of
irrelevant I think it'll make for
interesting TV I'm looking forward to
watching and I think the most
interesting thing we will see in the
debate is what type of spin is used by
Graham Cassady to deflect from the
undeniable empirical realities that this
type of bill it's not even about this
particular bill although it happens to
be right now because that's what's on
the table but this type of bill
cannot possibly reduce costs while
increasing access and improving care it
just can't happen it's not how the
numbers work and I've talked about this
before and will outline it again when
you say let's increase the ability of
for-profit insurance companies to make
more profit that's either going to
worsen quality or access or increase
cost or both it's just the simple math
of it and Gerald Friedman from my alma
mater the University of Massachusetts
has done some really good work outlining
not only B costs of Medicare for all or
single payer but also the savings and
it's very easy to just talk about the
costs of Medicare for all without
considering that the savings would
exceed the costs when we talk here about
the net impact of something like the
gramm cassidy bill they like to talk
about how it will for some people maybe
reduce cost or increase choice without
talking about all of the ways in which
it would increase costs decrease choice
and decrease care so in that sense we
don't need this debate if you have been
following how health insurance has
developed in the United States if you
understand sort of the basic tenets of
how profit modifies the relationship
between the insured and the insurers if
you have read for example former Cigna
executive wendell potter's book deadly
spin and you understand how we even got
this type of system to begin with you
don't need this debate to know exactly
what's going to happen if graham cassidy
passes but i still think it will be
interesting to see how they try to
defend it okay
now I'm going to get into some of the
specific sort of bullet points and
talking points that you should watch out
for if you're going to be watching the
debate because they're they're sort of
there are only certain arguments that
you can make to try to hide the horrible
reality of a bill like Graham Cassady
and I'm going to tell
you about what some of those are but
before doing that I mentioned Bernie
Sanders participating is interesting
because he is not just a random opposing
senator he is the senator that has
proposed a totally different way of
looking at health care he is proposed to
the Medicare for all 2017 bill and it
really comes down to a difference in
philosophy right if you believe that
health care is a product to be bought
and sold on the market the open market
like a new car and that not being able
to afford care is just like not being
able to afford a new car you either take
public transportation or you get a
cheaper car or you borrow a car or you
ask someone for a ride because it's just
a market it's the automobile market if
you believe that then it actually does
make sense that you would propose
something like Graham Cassidy now any
even superficial economic analysis would
immediately tell you well it doesn't
make sense for health care to be bought
and sold as if it were a normal good or
service subject to neoclassical
economics curves of supply and demand
the demand curve and the elasticity or
lack thereof of health care as a product
or service is nothing like that for
luxury sedans or high-end tasting menu
restaurants or whatever else right it is
very different it is a drastically
different type of demand curve and as
such any suggestion that the market
should be more involved in the
relationship between the insured and the
insurer z' is fundamentally flawed at
the base level if you believe that the
government has a responsibility to
provide some basic level of care to
everybody regardless of ability to pay
even if you don't believe that morally
if you understand that uninsured people
is actually bad policy and it's bad for
everybody it's bad when people don't
have insurance and use the emergency
room as primary care and you you still
end up paying for it right because the
hospitals have to account
the fact that uninsured individuals are
going to come in and not pay so they
have to raise their prices so that they
can raise the average amount of money
that they end up getting not what they
bill but what they end up getting from
each service or procedure that they
provide and as a result insurance
companies need to adjust premiums upward
for the exact same reason so your you're
not only the moral question is an
interesting question but I actually
think that if we're talking to
right-wingers it's not the best sort of
type of argument to make it's better to
make the argument that you're going to
pay for it either way and why not pay
for it upfront and have more predictable
costs than say well you know we would
people might come in people might use
the emergency room they might not we
don't really know so so fundamentally
we're talking about two different
philosophies now what can we expect to
hear in this debate couple different
things number one be particularly
attentive to the use of words by Graham
or Cassidy like necessarily and possibly
Mark what's his last name I forget his
last name but a White House policy
director or something along those lines
was interviewed by Chris Wallace on Fox
News Sunday yesterday Sunday and we
talked about this on the regular
broadcast program today and Chris
Wallace actually did a pretty good job
of pinning him down as to what will be
the impact on people with pre-existing
conditions and there's of course no way
to deny that many people with
pre-existing conditions if graham
cassidy were to pass would end up paying
more and there was this amazing moment
where mark whatever his name was I
forget mark Burton I don't remember his
last name where he said you won't
necessarily pay more you won't
necessarily pay more if you have a
pre-existing condition under Graham
Cassidy that's an admission that people
many people will pay more you have to
pay attention to the use of weasel words
like necessarily it will possibly lower
premiums for millions of Americans
possibly it will possibly lower premiums
it will increase premiums for millions
of Americans but it's possible that it
will lower premiums for millions of
Americans
these are the types of weasel words that
you have to pay very close attention to
and this is when they want to maintain
some plausible deniability so later when
premiums go up or people with
pre-existing conditions get price gouged
they can say we set up front this had
the possibility of saving people money
but it turns out it cost people more
money on the average now some of these
individuals that are trying to defend
this policy they'll just lie okay so
this guy on Fox News Sunday was at least
picking his words carefully so later you
couldn't say he was lying he said you
won't necessarily be screwed if you have
pre-existing condition all right he said
it wasn't necessary but it's possible or
even likely it's possible that you might
save money it's also possible that you
might not and the other thing you really
need to pay attention to particularly
when you know that I think it's both a
blessing and a curse that Bernie Sanders
is going to be there excellent debater
and someone who actually has the
knowledge of what an alternative system
would look like because he has worked
for a long time on what ultimately
became his medicare-for-all bill of 2017
having him there is great because he's a
great debater on this issue but it also
opens up Graham and Cassidy to respond
to Bernie Sanders with straw men or red
herrings Bernie Sanders might make a
great argument as to why truck Graham
cassadee is a bad idea and then Graham
Cassidy can say senator Sanders has
proposed a government takeover a total
government takeover of health care and
what's important to think about when you
hear that is any time they allege that
government will control or take over X
and that's bad they are suggesting the
alternative which is total business
control of whatever X is and implying
that we are better off if the profit
motive if business is motivated by the
Prophet by possible profit are making
decisions and when we look at other
countries at our level of development
the data is very clear people are better
off when there is not this for-profit
employer connected health care system
and you are eliminating that profit
motive now for-profit insurance
companies are much better off under the
type of system we have when people
profit in healthcare and this is like
the sick basic issue when you say here's
the cost of this procedure including
reasonable salaries for the people that
are working the fixed costs of the
health care facilities here's the cost
when you add profit above the cost what
is happening where what what what what
does that profit create it either makes
it more expensive for the user of health
care or if you keep the cost the same in
order to add profit you reduce the cost
either by you know trying to make
spending less on facilities having
understaffed facilities all factors that
make the care worse quality this this is
it right there's no other way that that
works and this is why what I people are
missing is you can't take Obama care if
this is Obama care and you can put Obama
care wherever you see it on the
political spectrum I think Obama care is
quite right-wing Obama care mandates
tens of millions of customers by
for-profit health insurance or pay a
fine right it is it is a boon to the
for-profit insurance industry so Obama
care it is not left-wing it is actually
a right-wing and it was conceived in the
90s by a right-wing think tank place
Obama care on the political spectrum
wherever you like allowing for-profit
companies to make more money by having
more freedom freedom to price P price
services however they want price
insurance however they want that's a
move to the right and when you do that
you price some people out and you
increase cost for many people and of
course what we can expect it here from
grammar Cassidy is well we're gonna make
up for the elimination of those Obama
care subsidies we're gonna feel like
Trump doing this you're gonna make up
for those Obama care subsidy removals by
adding block grants
of course the Block Grants will be for
far smaller amounts than the Obamacare
subsidies this is according to Graham
and Cassidy according to the bill and
states if they don't want to abide by
some of the restrictions that Graham
Cassady will attempt to put in they can
get a waiver right they can get a waiver
out altogether and that that that's just
it there's there's effectively no other
way around it that is the way that it is
going to work okay so these are some of
the things that I would encourage you to
sort of keep in mind as you're watching
the debate and I watching it and we will
probably have maybe we'll have reaction
tomorrow maybe we won't it sort of
depends I mean it looks like this bill
is on its way to failure and if that's
the case then I don't know how much
we'll really have to talk about it
tomorrow okay
let me talk about there's a bunch of
super chats that have been coming in and
I do want to talk about those calves a
our Bob has sent a to us dollar super
chat by using the dollar sign at the
bottom of the chat window how badly will
Bernie annihilate the dough tards I'm
not into this whole dotard thing and you
know I understand that a dotard is a new
word for a lot of people it was a new
word to me but the whole idea of [ __ ] I
mean it's still a little an allusion to
calling someone [ __ ] and I think
we've got many other ways that we can
criticize someone so I'm skipping the
the whole dotard thing
Jacob ball has sent a five-dollar super
chat Kurdistan is having an open
referendum Spain is arresting political
dissidents advocating for democracy
did I miss something well there's many
other news stories Jacob but yes those
things are happening those things are
happening and we will maybe we've talked
about the curtis kurdistan referendum we
did get a call I think we got a call
last week about the kind of Catalonian
sort of movement for independence so I
think that we will talk about that again
when there's more news okay Bailey
Marshall has sent a $5 supercharged do
you think Netanyahu's lobbying
to trump about gutting the Iran deal is
dangerous and what do you think about a
boss
getting Hamas to form a unity government
yeah so a couple things I actually have
notes let me see if I can pull them up
just because I had already done some
thinking about this okay so I mean
listen it's been no secret for a long
time that I am no fan no fan of Benjamin
Netanyahu I won't redo my entire rant
about Benjamin Netanyahu but I've not
been a fan of him for for a long time I
think he is not going to be an arbiter
to peace period I think that the the the
danger of Netanyahu lobbying Trump on
anything is that Netanyahu is a very
smart guy very very smart guy and Donald
Trump as we know is increasingly easy
increasingly and significantly easy to
influence and Netanyahu can probably get
Trump to do just about anything he wants
Putin probably can as well so I think
that a Netanyahu lobbying Trump about
gutting the Iran deal is dangerous that
doesn't mean that there aren't problems
with the Iran deal I've talked about
them we've been talking about the Iran
deal for a very long time Abbas getting
Hamas to form a unity government so the
news is that Hamas has agreed to some
steps towards a Palestinian Palestinian
unity government and you know I've
talked about this for a long time and
there there is not going to be any
reasonable peace agreement in the
israeli-palestinian conflict while Hamas
is sort of in charge of or managing or
speaking for Gaza and the Palestinian
people that are in Gaza so I think any
moves when you when you think about all
of the different factions there any move
to try to moderate who is going to be at
the negotiating table on the Palestinian
side I think that that's a really good
thing now Mahmoud Abbas there are things
we can say about him where we could say
it better better than Hamas and there's
no doubt about the
I completely agree with that but it's no
miraculous path a boss negotiating for
the entire for all of the Palestinian
territories is no secure path to
productive negotiations in the same way
that Benjamin Netanyahu is by no means a
path to that as well it's not clear that
either side really benefits from peace
at least in terms of those doing the
negotiating so I well well we're gonna
we've been dealing with this issue and
we're gonna continue dealing with it
Bailey Marshall has sent a $2 super chat
what do you think about Bernie's FP
interview I have not seen it I have not
seen it Bernie Sanders the interview I
wonder what was what there was in
particular about it but I have not I've
not seen it or by the way what does FP
is FP foreign policy was the interviewed
by foreign policy or was the interviewed
about foreign policy I've not seen it
but I will look it up blaze the commie
has sent a five-dollar super chat with
no question or comment thanks very much
Showtime 8 d7 has sent a $5 super set
super jet fresh haircut David do you
have a barber you religiously visit or
do you play Russian roulette at Great
Clips I play Russian roulette but not at
great clips I've never been to great
clips but I I do tend to just try
different people to cut my hair and it's
always more or less ok never great never
great I end up sort of having to wait
for for it to grow out but hey that's
where we are what can you do
Matthew Fisher has sent a $5 super chat
when it'll chuck a Nancy back
medicare-for-all it seems like the
Republicans kind of back it as the only
alternative to the Affordable Care Act I
don't know what Republicans are backing
Medicare for all I haven't seen that I
don't know that Chuck and Nancy will
back medicare for all because they are
they are the types of Democrats that
tend to be very similar to Republicans
on many issues ok I don't know how else
I can I can say it and I don't know that
I
Chuck Schumer or Nancy Pelosi are going
to be backing medicare-for-all
anytime soon not only can you contribute
through super chat you can contribute
through stream labs.com
/ the David Pakman show Purple Haze who
you see listed here at the top Purple
Haze onine has made a $5 contribution
and as you can see the only difference
between super chat five-dollar
contributions and stream Labs $5
contributions is that you see the number
of cents when you donate five dollars
through stream labs at stream labs comm
slash the david pakman show purple haze
oh nine saying since Jimmy Kimmel has
come into the political spotlight I've
been thinking a lot about comedic
political commentators have we reached
the point where comedians like Colbert
know Oliver etc are becoming more
accurate than the mainstream media I
think on accuracy we should go into all
assertions made by anybody commenting on
politics with healthy skepticism and do
the exact same type of due diligence
that we would do no matter what comments
are being made by anybody whether it is
Bernie Sanders or Charles Krauthammer or
Jimmy Kimmel
let's fact check let's do everything
that you know be a good student of media
literacy and critical thinking would do
that being said I think the more
interesting discussion around Jimmy
Kimmel is and Noah Trevor Noah I have
not I think that since Trevor Noah has
taken off oh I'm sorry
not I said no Oliver now I'm realizing
that the question was Stephen Colbert
Trevor Noah and John Oliver I think I've
only seen about five minutes of Trevor
Noah ever since he took over for John
Stewart so I can't speak to too much
about it but the point I want to make is
the following anybody saying that
comedians shouldn't do politics says who
what does that mean they shouldn't do
politics athletes shouldn't do politics
anyone is free and should be encouraged
to use the platform they have however
they do
side to use it now you might say well
the comedian might risk angering his
audience and putting people off or
something like that that's the free
market that the Wright claims to support
it's a free market of ideas and if
enough people say I don't like it when
Jimmy Kimmel does politics I don't like
it when athletes do politics by kneeling
or whatever else it is that they do stop
watching them stop buying the tickets
whatever and that is the free market
that that is literally the free market
of ideas right if you don't like the
ideas you can stop buying the tickets
you can stop watching Jimmy Kimmel or
whatever and the idea that based on your
role you're not supposed to do politics
I don't agree with now the exception
would be if there is a particular job
you've been hired for where you are
supposed to be a political right so an
example would be I mean I don't know
there's different different examples and
people would disagree but I guess I
would I would lean in the direction of
if you are hired to be a I'm actually
even struggling because I just I find
it's okay to do politics I think that if
you are hired by a TV station to
broadcast sports and they say
specifically we're hiring you to
broadcast sports and you decide to start
talking about politics particularly sort
of in a one-sided way then your employer
can say well that's that's not what we
hired you for now I still wouldn't have
a problem with it in the sense that if I
don't like the commentary if I don't
like how Al Michaels during a Patriots
game back during the 2004 election said
the refs flip-flopped on the call and
we're certainly in the right state for
that referring of course to the flip
flopper ad hominem that was created
around John Kerry at the time I don't
like it I don't have to watch all
Michaels and I don't watch all Michaels
I don't like out Michaels but but I just
I really don't have a problem with
people interjecting politics everything
is political and I think it is it is a
good thing to try to use whatever
platform you have in the way you believe
you will be most impactful your employer
might not like it your audience might
not not like
your clients might not like it but that
I don't have a problem with that
Brian dang has sent a $2.00 super chat
saying dotard dotard is pronounced
dotard not like [ __ ] okay that's fine
I'm just not participating in the entire
dotard thing but by all means have at it
for those those who are interested in
that it doesn't bother me but yeah I
just find myself not caring about it
there's so much other stuff to discuss
okay let's do some thank yous as I
mentioned I'm trying to reduce the
number of the amount of time I spend
talking about membership and patreon
during the live streams but I do want to
talk about it a little because you know
to be perfectly honest we are in sort of
a funding crunch at the David Pakman
show and we're trying to replace the
money that we've lost as a result of the
YouTube advertiser boycott this is our
YouTube ad revenue we started the year
really strong and it's done
YouTube is basically done as a revenue
source so we're trying to replace that
revenue in other ways
membership is one of the ways that we do
that it's our primary source of revenue
members get access to the world-famous
bonus show they get access to the
commercial free broadcast program so
instead of watching four to six minute
clips on YouTube you get the entire
one-hour show with no commercials every
day on YouTube really really great thing
you can sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership we do have a 40%
discount coupon code and a couple people
who have signed up just while we've been
chatting here katia McCloud
Howard Gruber Adam Rodriguez and Katie
Hickman Katie Hickman all of whom have
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership genuinely thank you thank you
it has been ever since March 31st when
the YouTube ad boycott problem started
March 31st is sort of day zero in this
world it has been really really tough it
has been really really tough and you
would imagine that having our YouTube
issues covered in the New York Times by
a man to have
would have really brought a lot of
attention towards the issues and and
maybe a lot of new contributors you
would have thought that having coverage
in wired by Devi Alba great article by
Devi Alba about what's going on with the
David Pakman show YouTube channel but
the truth is it didn't the neither of
those articles brought in a huge influx
of contributors to what we're doing so
we've got our couple methods we've got
membership that's number one
we've got patreon patreon.com slash
david pakman show we used to not have
patron benefits at patreon.com slash
david pakman show but enough people said
David you know I'd be much more likely
to contribute if there were some perks
to patreon contribution so we now have
them right at the $2 a month level you
get the Members Only supporter only
monthly newsletter at the $5 a month
level you get the newsletter and access
to the world-famous bonus show that we
do every day and at the ten dollar level
on patreon you get all of the prior
benefits as well as access to the full
commercial free show every single day so
even if you can only throw in a dollar
or two please don't think that because
you can only throw that much in it's not
worth it I've said this before and I'll
say it again only about one to one and a
half percent of our total audience
contributes anything right and and I'm
ok with that because we do the show as a
public service we distribute the show at
our expense to 200 radio and TV stations
because I think it's important to get
those stations the program so that they
can broadcast it we do that at our
expense but if we could go from one and
a half one to one and a half percent of
our audience supporting us to three
percent of our audience applauding us we
never have to worry about this funding
issue I mean it's just it I don't have
to talk about membership I don't have to
talk about patreon that's how small the
level of support is and that's why even
just getting to 3% support and thank you
Christina for your contribution
just getting the three percent of our
audience supporting us would be
absolutely absolutely huge so please get
those contributions in and I will do
more thank yous as we go here
and I will deal with a couple of these
other super chats and questions etc that
we have let me get to Christina okay
Christina sent a dollar stream Labs
contribution at stream labs comm slash
the david pakman show saying stream Labs
is giving me a hard time tonight seeing
if I can get it to work well you did
Christina it worked beautifully it
worked beautifully
Ian D has sent a $2 super chat where is
Ian's there it is Ian D donated $2
through super chat asking will the ad
boycott impact on political discussion
you know I think it will so for people
actually I kind of have horrible
horrible news about the YouTube ad
boycott the YouTube ad boycott started
on March 31st and what happened was that
some coke coca-cola and other big
advertisers had ads that appeared on
YouTube before obviously racist content
so there was sort of panic at YouTube
and YouTube turned on a super aggressive
ad filtering algorithm and what that did
was it turned off ads from anything that
was even remotely controversial and the
algorithm couldn't distinguish between a
video by white supremacists advocating
for white supremacy and me doing a video
explaining why white supremacy is bogus
right neither one was getting ads a
major major problem since that algorithm
has started to improve so we have been
getting more ads but we've been getting
low quality ads and we've also been
getting ads that don't align nearly as
well with the points of view of our
program and this has always been the
case like there's always been the
sporadic NRA ad on our videos but now
from from the screenshots people are
sending me the ads are just totally out
of whack with the subject matter of our
program the ideology of the program we
now are dealing with ad boycott level 2
and it's not D monetization its
limitation okay and other youtubers
might know about this a month before
last
basically our two months ago there were
two statuses two statuses for videos on
YouTube the you either have monetization
on or you have monetization off right
monetization off means the video is not
appropriate for YouTube advertisers and
a general YouTube audience no ads are
running ads on means that ads are
running there is a new status an
intermediate status called limited
status limited status means that the
video is not strictly speaking on
monetizable but that fewer ads may run
and the really sort of pernicious thing
that's going on is that a huge portion
of our and many other youtubers
libraries have been limited and the
limited thing is is much more dangerous
for two reasons number one the videos
are being limited in waves so we went
through every single video in our
library that had been marked as limited
about a month ago and we appealed every
single one of those limitations asking
for a manual review now the manual
review will only happen I believe it's
when the video generates by itself a
thousand views a week now a lot of these
videos are older right so they're not
generating a thousand views a week or I
don't remember the exact amount but in
total we're talking about thousands of
videos in total they are generating lots
of views every single week and those are
effectively making no money now we
thought that that was an initial review
of our entire library we reviewed we
asked for a review and that's done we
went back and looked last week and a
whole new series of older videos have
been flagged for limited ads so once
again we have to devote staff time to
asking for every single one of those
videos to be reviewed because a lot of
them are really innocuous like not at
all controversial no adult content no
gore no swearing nothing and we're
running into this issue once again so I
I do I believe that the ad boycott will
impact political discussions because I'm
trying not to do this I am making every
effort not to change the subject matter
of the
program based on anticipating whether it
will run ads or not because if if I was
just concerned with monetizing YouTube
as much as possible I wouldn't do
anything controversial I wouldn't talk
about natural disaster as those those
might be those might be limited in ads I
wouldn't talk about North Korea wouldn't
talk about the israeli-palestinian
conflict wouldn't talk about Venezuela
wouldn't talk about war Isis all this
stuff cuz none of that stuff is gonna
make barely any money on YouTube I don't
want to do that right I want to talk
about the issues that I want to talk
about but there are going to be people
who will say and I'll just pick topics
that will be fully monetized so I can
make money and that will impact the
political discussion absolutely no doubt
about it okay a couple other stream Labs
contributions you can contribute at
stream labs comm slash the David Pakman
show
Christina sent a two dollar and fifty
cent stream Labs contribution have you
recently purchased new shirts that
you've been wearing on the show also do
you keep shirts at the studio or do the
show in what you arrive in very good and
specific questions I have no new shirts
I recently I'm going to try to get a
couple new shirts because this really
weird thing happens where I rip through
the elbow on a lot of my shirts and I
don't know why it might be when every
day I reach over my head to put my
earpiece in which I hear the guests
through at the studio I think I'm like
putting tension on the elbow of the
shirts and I've got five or six shirts
that have a hole through the through the
elbow you can wear them with a sweater
over it but in any case I've got to
start replacing some of them so I need
to do that soon now that it's becoming
fall I don't keep shirts at the studio I
wear to the studio the shirt I will be
wearing thank you ironic cat has sent a
$2.00 stream lapse contribution meow
what passions Drive you also any good
news diamonds in the mire of media crap
lately there's some piecemeal good news
about the steps forward that some
European and Asian countries are taking
on battling climate change and moving in
the direction of alternative energy I
think that that's interesting I think
there are some really interesting sort
of shared
I might call them socialistic companies
that are that are basically being run as
coops my former UMass economics
professor economist Richard Wolff has
been writing and and speaking about some
of these on his podcast yeah I think
there's some good news as far as what
passions drive me
really you can see the passions on the
show right equality fairness democracy
media literacy and I'm really really I'm
teaching at Boston College which I'm
doing now as a part-time adjunct
professor has really sort of illuminated
to me that I really am interested in
teaching media literacy critical
thinking and epistemology and sort of
how to look at media and understand what
is being said and oftentimes just as
importantly what is not being said and
so that that I think is definitely
another passion of mine
Claudius Augustus has sent a $2.00
stream labs contribution would you say a
little more on your assessment of the
German general election I'm sorry of the
German election result as it effects
brexit tomorrow tomorrow I'm still
forming my perspective on the Germany
election results Evon see have sent a
dollar-fifty stream labs.com slash the
david pakman show contribution
contribution what's your opinion on a
democracy blockchain democracy liquid
democracy etc I'm a big fan myself and I
think it's a cause that progressives
should be fighting for in the future to
fight corruption and give more people a
say what are your thoughts liquid
democracy I don't know much about let's
see what what happens if I google them
liquid democracy also known as
delegative democracy is a form of
democratic control whereby an electorate
vests voting power in delegates rather
than in representatives the term is a
generic description of either already
existing or proposed popular control
apparatus as interesting I want to
research more before I comment on that
I've been reading quite a bit about
blockchain democracy and I think that
there is definitely something very very
interesting there I've also read some
analyses suggesting that
the blockchain fervour that has been
visible lately may be overblown but I
were actually we're sort of thinking
about the blockchain element is maybe
worthy of a long-form piece and that
comes both with the sort of crypto
currency side and other more political
or uses for democracy of blockchain and
by a democracy I don't know what you
mean I don't know exactly it's a
combination Digital democracy or
internet democracy incorporates 21st
century information and communications
technology to promote democracy I mean
in its component parts I've been a major
advocate of that for a long time I'm
actually interested in some of these
terms I didn't know that they these have
been sort of discreetly defined as
movements or ideologies so that's pretty
interesting I'm gonna look into that
more but Christina has sent a to dollar
and 50 cent super chat does the show
provide healthcare to those who work on
the show what will happen to you and Pat
if Obamacare is repealed you have to
take care of Pat if things go wrong with
a capital W so the Pat's under 26 so
right now really the the only person
who's in a situation right now of
meeting care on the open market is me
because I'm over 26 and Massachusetts
has actually had a system that goes
above and beyond the requirements of
Obamacare for some time and it sort of
is colloquially called Romney care so
hopefully a repeal of Obamacare wouldn't
have a huge impact in Massachusetts
although it would definitely impact some
of the funding that's received and I
just buy insurance through one of those
marketplaces I am buying for-profit
insurance as are most most or many
people in my situation okay let's jump
over to okay a couple different things
number one I do have kind of a sad
on patreon but I do have one new patron
to thank Eric Andrew Emmanuel s'en has
pledged $5.00 a month I'm really kind of
getting bummed out about hey I'm trying
to do I'm going by what the audience has
asked for which is no telethon style
patreon fundraisers during live streams
but I'm really getting bummed out by how
it's going we've been talking here for
about 45 minutes and we only have one
new patreon contributor and even if you
can only throw in a dollar I think it
would really brighten the evening for
everybody if we could get a few more
patreon contributions in even if they're
just a dollar and of course at two five
and ten dollars there are really really
great member benefits and if we get
although I'd like to be cautiously
optimistic we started the evening with
1933 patrons I suggested that if we got
to 1950 I would create for you a huge 55
percent discount code for membership and
we're only one closer we're at 1934 I'm
just I'm just bummed out it's just sad
but if anybody wants to jump in here I
will give you an extra good live shout
out and thank you and make up some
probably untrue but really really great
sounding praise for everybody who makes
those contributions and I do have one
other new member to thank as well you
can become a member at david pakman.com
slash membership the coupon code that
saves you 40% as I voted 17 Linda
Delgado
Linda Delgado thank you thank you for
becoming a member every single new
member helps to replace the lost revenue
from the YouTube advertiser boycott so
thank you very much okay let's look at
some of the other super chance Garrett
North has sent a ten dollar super chat
really important issue why in your
opinion has Trump said barely anything
about the crisis in Puerto Rico simple
answer he doesn't know Puerto Rico's
part of the United States right that
that would be the sort of base answer
that my mind immediately goes to let's
assume for a second he does think that
Puerto Rico is part of the United States
clearly his priorities are
to tweet about football players kneeling
and to talk about repealing the
Affordable Care Act it's it's just not
his priorities those are not his
priorities and I I don't I I don't know
that we even have to go further it's
just the guy doesn't care he doesn't
care
Brian Rasmussen has sent the $5 super
chat David do you have any hope that
citizens united will ever be overturned
uh I mean listen I would like the effect
of citizens united to be overturned
excuse me thirsty feeling like Marco
Rubio here tonight I would love citizens
united to be overturned I don't know if
the most direct path is overturning
Citizens United specifically to changing
the sort of campaign finance system or
maybe looking at restructuring other
aspects of campaign finance that don't
require the repeal and again I'm
thinking sort of pragmatically but yes I
do have hope that citizens united will
be overturned dana alexander has sent a
five-dollar super check my dad is
Hispanic and a big Trump supporter so
I'm curious how you debate people close
to you who have Fox News lol and I'll
support you on patreon Thank You Dana
look forward to welcoming you as a new
patron I am increasingly thinking you
know it's different when it's people
close to you and people not close to you
but I think it is more or less futile to
try to sort of like change the minds of
Trumpets by beating them over the head
with facts I think it's probably better
to employ a Socratic style method of
questioning inquire as to how people
came to the conclusions that they they
have come to ask them how that might be
wrong ask them how they would figure out
if they were wrong I think that's a
better use of time really no matter who
you're talking to I don't know I'm
increasingly sort of going in that
direction
Jacob ball sent the $2 super chat do it
I guess he means telethon David the
Patriots will understand and following
up with another $2 Super chat hashtag
thirsty David I am feeling thirsty
I went for a run earlier and I must
still be sort of dehydrated from it okay
so I think we have we have gotten caught
up on super chats remember there are two
ways to send questions and comments one
is by using stream labs.com slash the
david pakman show the other is by using
the super chat button that's the dollar
sign at the bottom of the chat window
and both are both are great options now
I'm seeing here oh I see they're just
sort of out some of these donations are
out of order I gotcha I see what's going
on okay so for people just now tuning in
and wondering what is going on what is
going on with the live debate on health
care the live debate starts at 9:00 p.m.
Eastern right it's 848 p.m. Eastern so
we're doing sort of like a preview if
you go back to the beginning of the
stream you will see my long rant I was
almost completely out of breath and
completely flummoxed by the end of it
because I spoke about 25 minutes
non-stop with red herrings to watch out
for distractions to watch out for
talking points to be prepared for for
this debate we're going to see about
Trump Care 3.0 at the top of the hour I
would be interested if you if you're
watching this later if you've already
seen the debate look at the red herrings
and straumann that I warned about and
see whether I'm ultimately vindicated
and I mean really vindicated not like
Trump who thinks he's vindicated with
Obama wiretapped me because he's not but
actually vindicated because I have a
feeling we're gonna see a lot of those
okay I I want to interrupt for a moment
with very very good news apparently my
being bummed out about the lack of
patreon contributions has spurred a
number of contributors jacob wilkins has
made a pledge of $1 a month
Thank You Jacob you are an incredible
basketball player and I think that
that's absolutely an incredible thing
I'm doing fake praise like I don't
really know that much about these folks
but I'm just trying to heap praise upon
you
Ian Diggs who I've never seen a better
computer programmer than
Diggs he has pledged $5.00 a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show who
else do we have here
Jackson Sullivan I've never met a nicer
person than Jackson Sullivan Jackson
helps old ladies cross the street and
holds the door for everybody a really
good person Jackson Sullivan has made a
$2 a month pledge Dana Alexander has
pledged $1 a month and Dana from a young
age has helped kids be entrepreneurial
and she has launched over a thousand
lemonade stands by helping kids around
the world and that's a really really
great cause adam silverstein has made a
pledge of $1 a month and adam is known
within his community boy I'm running out
of ideas
Adam is known for being a really big
time supporter of independent media and
Frank tolentino has made a $2 a month
pledge as well and Frank is just an
all-around great family person Frank is
just really really well-known as being
the person that his family can always
count on and it's an honor Frank really
to have you as a supporter so we've we
started the evening at 1933 patrons we
are at nineteen forty I will reiterate
my offer we've got nine minutes left
till this debate starts at the top of
the hour if we can get just 10 more
patrons in the next nine minutes that
will get us to 1950 and I will create
and release for you a 55 percent
membership discount code we have failed
numerous times recently to achieve the
number of patrons to trigger one of
those discount codes let's do it tonight
I think we can do it it's it's bumming
me out that we haven't made them but I
think we're going in that direction okay
super chats mighty Sun Losada has sent a
$2 super chat joining the bandwagon
hashtag I guess it's thirsty David it's
supposed to be okay
jacob ball has sent a $2 super chat
Pakman has the greatest audience doesn't
he folks and not only the greatest
audience but probably the biggest
audience ever
ever seen for a David Pakman show pre
healthcare debate live stream on the
25th of a month of September big time
Big Time stuff okay
let's go to our stream Labs
contributions stream labs comm slash the
David Pakman show
Christina has sent a dollar stream labs
question this is a really good question
do you have a hard time maintaining
friendships and relationships with
people who have vastly different views
from your own I have very few
friendships with people who have
drastically different political views
from me and you know if we disagree on
tax policy it's pretty easy to maintain
a friendship or a relationship if we
disagree on things like you know gay
marriage or sort of are people poor
because they want to be and because
they're lazy or are their systemic
reasons why people are poor if we
disagree on that our views on the world
are so different that it's going to be
really difficult to really see
eye-to-eye on almost any issue so I have
very few relationships with people with
drastically different political views
the ones that I do have are people that
have known for a really really long time
and and our relationships sort of like
predate me even being involved in
politics and we basically do not talk
about politics I mean we just don't and
that's that I mean that I it's sad it
really is very very sad but I don't know
how else to say it I just it's it's the
reality and I know a lot of people who
have contacted me particularly in the
Trent Barrow who say I really can't
maintain relate relationships with
trumpets I I just can't and we had a
there's a great call about a woman who
called into the show live who explained
it's pretty bad between her who
supported Bernie and her Trump
supporting husband and that it's
impacting their sex life as well so a
lot of a lot of drama a lot of drama
okay let's see what else we have here
other questions to ask have
that have been asked or to answer I want
to share more good news with you we have
received two more patreon contributions
or one new one and one increase Nikko
has increased their pledge from two
dollars a month three dollars a month
thank you and Brian Rasmussen has
pledged five dollars a month and I
really appreciate that from Brian Brian
is a tremendous humanitarian Brian
really cares about animal rights and I
think it's absolutely tremendous Brian
your activism within the animal rights
community I don't know what I'm talking
about and let me just do a couple new
member thank-yous because we do have a
couple of new members
Gisela Ventura has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership and Matthew
McMillan has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership we have
there anybody here that there was a very
strange noise I don't know what that was
it sounded like someone
it sounded like physical violence I
don't know if that came through on my
microphone we've got about five minutes
left in the stream because then it is
going to be time for the healthcare
debate which is what we've been talking
about and talking about a lot tonight so
if we can get nine more patrons nine
more patrons in the next five minutes
that'll get us the nineteen fifty and
then I will create and release for you a
fifty five percent discount code a 55
percent membership discount code just
for you and it won't tell anybody else
about it it'll be our little secret and
I think you will all really really enjoy
that but we do have only at this point
four minutes left we are getting very
very close to the debate yeah people
saying that they did hear that noise I
don't know if that was an animal or if
that was a person but it was a very
strange noise and these are these are
external walls so I don't know very
bizarre
imagine if I put up the blind and
there's someone in the window that would
be horrifying absolutely horrifying
so reminder let's own Thank You mighty
so that for the dollar contribution I
appreciate that watch for the red
herrings tonight watch for Bernie to be
attacked for his medicare-for-all
proposal even though what's actually
supposed to be debated tonight is Trump
Care 3.0 which is a disaster look for ad
homonyms against Bernie Sanders and also
look for weasel words I said this before
and I'll say it again if a gram or
Cassidy tonight say you won't
necessarily see premiums go up under
Trump care 3.0 necessarily is the key
word there you might see a decrease in
your premiums under Trump care 3.0 that
is a sign that many people are going to
see an increase in their premiums
understand the language that is going to
be used if it is indeed be going to be
used and I believe that we are going to
see a lot of this a lot of this weasel
language tonight I want to say a big
thank you to Samuel Wood Samuel is an
existing patron who just edited his
pledge from $2 a month
to $5 a month thank you very much Samuel
I appreciate that we are still holding
steady at 1941 patrons we started the
evening at 1933 we are now at 1941 and
we are still sort of standing by still
three minutes that we could really get
to that 1950 low any any one of you can
make it happen
Darrin Gaines has sent the $20 super
Chad the super chat all star of the
night that's the biggest single
contribution that we saw tonight be a
super chat thanks very much Darrin
Darrin saying only keep up the great
work and let me take the last couple
minutes to give you a quick update I
mentioned this last time there was
significant interest expressed in this I
have been teaching a class at Boston
College as an adjunct professor and I
suggest that it might be interesting for
me to redo those lectures with the
slides I use in class and do them as
like 75
minute presentations on YouTube for our
YouTube audience the reaction to that
has been huge people seem to be
absolutely loving absolutely loving and
thanks Brian for that contribution the
idea of doing those lectures
the thing is 75 minute long-form pieces
with slides intermixed is a lot of work
it is a lot a lot of work so we need to
figure out the sort of finances of
making that happen I want to make it
happen but that is a lot of staff time
it is a lot of staff time in addition to
producing The Daily Show
Jacob Ball has sent a $20 and one cent
super chat saying suck it Darren
shots have been fired besting Darren
Gaines as the top contributor the top
contributor of the evening and clearly
people are getting very very agitated
here and they want they want to be the
top contributor of the evening thank you
thank you to everybody who has been
making those contributions and on that
note it is time for the debate let's all
go and watch but before I do that there
might be was there one more contribution
here from Christina yes have a good
night David I always have a bit of a
giggle while watching love the show
thanks again thank you and let's go
watch the debate see what happens